they are inseparable but even Dave
Chappelle who is a very good comedian
came in and he got on this this
bandwagon supporting the peaceful riots
he did so for a sort of interesting
reason so he opens up his new his new
comedy set talking about George Floyd
not in a comedic way he's just talking
about it very seriously
then he criticized our friend Candace
Owens which also wasn't funny it was
just a vulgar kind of line it wasn't
even a joke then he defended these idiot
celebrities that we just saw giving
their opinions and it was kind of
interesting how he defended them because
he said people trust celebrities that's
why they keep going back and watching
them they do have an influence in a
platform and so it makes sense for them
to talk and I guess that's true
we shouldn't trust them for much of what
they have to say about politics if we
only know them for being good at
performing on camera you know if we only
know them for being good at reading
lines other people have written for them
but we do and and that's a reality in
Dave Chappelle's acknowledging that but
then the most interesting part is how
Dave Chappelle defends the riots no less
than 400 police officers showed up and
answer the call boy let me tell you
something they Swiss cheese is dead as
dead could be he is done and you know
why four hundred cops showed up because
one of their own was murdered so how the
can't they understand what's going on in
these streets we saw ourselves like you
see yourself Dave is actually making
about half a good point here and the
thing that's funny is because he
attacked Candace Owens in his set he
then later goes on apparently
obliviously
to make the same point Candace Owens did
on identity what Candice Owens said in
her video was I don't identify with
George Floyd I know that people are
trying to say that I need to have racial
solidarity with George Floyd but I don't
identify with George Floyd and I
disagree with the decision to elevate
people who commit a lot of crimes
as representatives of the community
that's her point whether you agree with
it or disagree with it that's the point
she was making and so she's saying I
don't identify with him simply in the
basis of his race and what Chappelle is
saying is we must identify with these
people simply on the basis of their race
the reason why when when cops get killed
why the cops show up overwhelmingly to
take down the criminal which is the
first part of the story he's telling is
because they killed one of their own and
now when someone kills one of our own we
show out in the streets what is your
identity where do you find your identity
the left is trying to stoke all sorts of
identity racial identity I've know not
white identity but for every other race
they've trying to stoke racial identity
politics sexual identity if you're
attracted to men and you're a man or if
you're a man who identifies as a woman
they're trying to stoke that sort of
thing class ident you know socioeconomic
class identity do you not make a lot of
money dude yes make a lot of money
they're trying to stoke all of these
kinds of identity and they're all pretty
shallow the one identity that they're
trying to destroy is American identity
that's why they're trying to tear down
the statues they're trying to stare down
nah just robert e lee they're trying to
tear down Christopher Columbus and they
are gonna tear down George Washington
where it hasn't happened already will
happen soon okay
that's the the only identity that in any
way can make this nation work is if you
have a strong perhaps even primary or at
least up at the top identity as an
American regardless of your race
regardless of your sexual preferences
whatever that is ebbing away I mean they
are now openly protesting the American
flag which is the symbol of that very
identity and they're stoking all of the
other kinds and even guys who are
usually fairly insightful or funny like
Dave Chappelle are agreeing with that
take on it where is your identity going
to be that's the question
[Music]
[Music]